one of them was 23 and she had been very
severely bulimic in her teenage years
and had been hospitalized a few times
because she was going to die otherwise
and then when she was 18 she
unfortunately looked up online if it was
possible to get your breasts removed
without having breast cancer and she
found Top surgery
and a week later she had decided that
she was a trans man and when she went to
a gender Clinic the therapist said to
her that's why you're trying to starve
yourself because you're not meant to
have curves because you're really a boy
and so she told her parents and her
parents were delighted because they had
seen their daughter nearly die and they
were like yeah yeah if this is going to
save you you do this so she got her
ovaries removed her uterus removed she
took testosterone she was getting ready
for phalloplasty which is the most
brutal surgery imaginable where they
take off an enormous chunk of either
your leg or your arm and turn it into a
fake dick so she looked online then um
you know what do I do after a
hysterectomy because she still felt
terrible because they lied to her about
how easy all these operations are
hysterectomies are really tough
operations and she found all these sites
of women who had used Rhine cancer or
you know that sort of thing and they
were very supportive
she started talking to them and then one
day the sentence floated into her mind
and it was just how can an operation
that is only done on women turn me into
a man and it was like the whole thing
the whole past five years just Unwound
and she was back and she was like oh
this was nonsense and I listened to her
tell this story and I just sat there and
I thought oh [ __ ] hell they are
sterilizing gay kids
um
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constantine kitchen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our brilliant guest today is
somebody we've been Keen to have on the
show for a very long time she's the
director of advocacy at sex matters and
the author of trans a brilliant book
that we do have but because she's one of
our first guests in the new studios in a
box somewhere but it is a brilliant book
Helen Joyce welcome to trigonometry
thank you for having me on uh it's a
real pleasure to have you on for anyone
who doesn't know who you are tell
everybody who are you what's been your
journey through life how are you sitting
here in that chair talking to us well a
long time ago I was an academic I
studied mathematics and then I became a
journalist and from 2005 until earlier
this year I worked at The Economist
doing various jobs I finished with being
written editor but during that time I
got interested in this strange new idea
that men could be women and women could
be men and I eventually became so
interested in that I wrote a book about
it called trans when ideology meets
reality which came out now a year and a
half ago and then became so interested
that I left that job and go and work
with sex matters which is a human rights
organization which focuses on sex-based
rights so the human rights that are
sex-based that require you to notice
who's male and who's female and that's
what I'm going to keep doing I'm not
going back to the economist that makes
sense well that's what we wanted to talk
with you about however as you know we
have had many many people on the show to
talk about this issue yeah and I suppose
the Curious Thing about you is is it
your mathematics background that you're
sort of just like
you know zero zero and one is one and
like I I can't stand this because a lot
of people are more flexible perhaps on
on yeah that's exactly right that is why
I got into it um and that's not the
usual way like usually people are more
pragmatic I mean I think I'm quite a
pragmatic person but I didn't start from
there people normally it's they notice
and they think what's happening in
schools or the indoctrination of kids or
they notice that there are men playing
in women's sports because they say
they're women or they they notice that
women's spaces like refuges and so on
are under threat or they just notice the
sexism of saying that how you perform
sex stereotypes is what makes you a man
or a woman
and of course I think all of those
things too but that wasn't what I
noticed first what I noticed first was
that if you say
trans women or women that's logically
equivalent to saying a woman is anyone
who says they're a woman and that's a
circular definition
so in mathematics a circular definition
doesn't get off the ground like if I
just say you know a chair is anything
that we Define as a chair it doesn't
give you any idea what a chair is you
actually need to give some outside input
into the definition
and that bothered me because it just
didn't seem right but I didn't know for
a while like why what sort of problems
it would create
so for me the journey in was that sort
of you know
highfalutin whatever um intellectual
Journey like you know this this doesn't
sound right this doesn't sound like
something that you can base laws and
policies and rules and regulations on
and so if proved you know if you destroy
a core definition like that it's amazing
how it pops up all over the place and
rules and regulations and laws because
although we don't make many distinctions
between men and women anymore the way
that we used to like it used to be only
men who could vote or only men who could
own property or only women who could do
this that or the other there are still
differences men are not women and women
are not men and those differences are
reflected in law in places where they
need to be maternity leave Rape Crisis
centers you know Sports those sorts of
things and we've broken all of those
things and we're watching that breakage
Ripple out through an entire system of
rules regulations institutions
governments Charities all sorts and it's
quite horrifying and where do you think
this comes from Helen because I'm quite
persuaded by the argument that and I
don't hear many people making this
argument but I'm sort of thinking about
more and more that it is the development
of technology that allows people to you
know transition more more effectively if
you like and and to pass more as other
sector and so on that sort of opened
this up and because of that we are now
in the position they're in there are
other people go well it's the academics
in the 60s and where do you think this
comes from
I think like all really interesting and
strange phenomena it's a perfect storm
like a lot of things arrived at the same
point together
I think there probably have always been
people who have thought that they would
like to be the opposite sex or that they
were meant to be the opposite sex
and we used to know until we'd forgotten
like how that worked out like how that
happened
and so you know in the 70s and 80s there
were these prospective studies where
they identified little boys who said
ardently that they thought they were
meant to be little girls and they
followed them into adulthood and what
they were was gay
because there's a strong very strong
link between being really highly gender
non-conforming in childhood early
childhood and growing up to be gay
um so those kids they look around them
they don't they're not born thinking I
was meant to be a girl or I was meant to
be a boy they look around them and they
think why am I so different why are
people treating me like this you know
why do I not fit in why does my dad drag
me out to rugby matches and grab my
Barbie doll away from me or whatever you
know so those kids they learn from the
society that they're in that they should
have been the opposite sex there's
always been that
and so some of those kids just grow up
and they they work out they're gay and
that's fine I mean I should say it's not
all that they're gay but anyway it's
just like strong statistical link
um so there was always that and then
Along Came medical technology that
allowed you know some surgeries and so
on quite brutal surgeries and not
terribly effective still
but anyway those surgery started then I
do think the academics had something to
do with it
um you know there's this whole move
since you know post-modernism what they
call the postmodern turn which is when
you stop thinking that words describe
reality and you start thinking words
create reality and the thing is both of
those things are true you know words do
create reality they start wars they you
know they make things happen but they
also describe reality I can't just say
any word means what I like and still
live in a world where you know
trains run and operations are successful
and you know that sort of thing
so it's the postmodern turn is like
moving away from the reality and towards
the words and then they just get like a
kind of intoxicated on it and unmoored
from anything and then Along Comes the
internet
and I would say that's the last of the
pieces I would pick out that um you know
in an internet World in an online world
you forget that you're actually a
physical being very easily like you live
through your avatar you see people on
screens you're not doing manual labor
um you know we've delayed Char bearing
people have fewer children lots of
people have no children you just you
just can actually pretend much more
successfully that men and women are just
more similar than they are
so yeah I mean that's not all of it by
any means by the book if you want to
know the whole story but you know those
are the bits I'd pick out to get us
where we are where we say that there's
no difference between men and women or
that men and women are arbitrary
categories that we can redefine as we
wish but Helen there's also as well
several strands to this because uh the
people or normally men who transition
later on in life are very different like
we say to young boys who want to
transition but also the young girls who
will then want to transition to be boys
that's a completely different thing
entirely as well isn't it men and women
are different and their motivations for
wanting to be the opposite sex are very
different too
um and then sexualities are different
most people are straight a few people
are gay some people are you know on a
spectrum of bisexuality in between so
those people are going to have different
motivations as well and you see it's
funny how you see the differences
between men and women more clearly when
you look at men and women who don't want
to be men and women so I mean by and
large the women who transition
are a lesbian if they're adults or
they're teenage girls who are going
through adolescence and finding it tough
adolescence always is tough but for
girls you know there's a whole
you know it's earlier than it used to be
you may be 11 when men start gorping at
your tits and you know it's not very
pleasant and you think life would be
easier as a boy uh and then you look
online and you say why do I feel so
uncomfortable with my body why do I feel
uncomfortable being me and the answer
you'll get is trans
no that wasn't true 10 years ago 10
years ago you got better advice but now
the advice is if you think you may be
trans you probably are
so that's that bunch and then the little
boys uh yeah I mean they're very
effeminate little boys and there's still
a lot of homophobia out there you know
there really are people who look at a
little boy in a dress who says that his
favorite toy is a Barbie doll and think
Hmm we'll see about that
and then the adult men I mean you know
the fact is probably three to five
percent of men are erotic cross-dressers
like we knew that you know those surveys
were done before this latest
uh pretends that men can be women they
find this an erotic idea to be a woman
to to inhabit the role of a woman
um you know you would have kept that at
the weekend and cross-dressing parties
maybe you know between you and your wife
20 years ago now you're stunning and
brave and that lady comes and you get
you know you get
societal claudits for what is actually
just a neurotic interest so are you
saying that um that some men or a lot of
men who transition later on in life it's
an erotic thing for them it's sort of
fetish almost yeah
okay I mean you can see that if you look
if you if you actually look at the you
know the
the chat rooms and the Reddit the
subreddits and so on clearly it is I
mean they're not you know they're not
dressing in Dowdy women's clothes
they're not heading you know they're not
putting on T-shirt and jeans and heading
out to you know
pick up the shopping and the kid from
Nursery or something it's very it's very
very
sexualized
it's all about heels and lipstick and
you know
ah
yeah I mean it's it's just quite obvious
once you stop thinking that it's an
identity and start thinking like what's
your motivation here mate
and so why is it why isn't it that we've
been able to have this discussion in a
Frank and open and honest manner well
the thing is that there's a big
difference between that particular
erotic interest the interest in being a
member of the opposite sex and other
erotic interests which is that if you
say it you ruin it
so if a man's entire erotic
um identity is wrapped up around
being a woman
he's not it's not about pretending to be
a woman it's about being a woman and the
moment when you say you you know you
know you don't pass or um
well you know fair enough like played
play it being a woman if you want but
don't use the women's toilets or
something like that you've just
destroyed the whole thing it can't it's
not a role player the magic is ruined
yes so it's the love that would really
rather you did not speak its name it's
not in phrase I coined it's an another
author thought of that and so for those
people part of the erotic interest is in
stopping people talk about the fact that
it's an erotic interest
and also getting other people to play
along because you can't be a woman or be
a man really on your own anymore like
it's about moving around the world as
that and that you know because there are
no places that you can go and be a woman
or be a man anymore except places that
only men or only women are meant to go
it actually means that you must go and
try and use women's spaces that's the
that's the thrill
you know everyone can wear what they
like now like you know in in a big city
like London or somewhere you can wear
what the hell you like a man can go
around and make up lipstick nail polish
anything he likes doesn't have to say
he's a woman to do that so to be a woman
you've got to go and use women's
changing rooms on women's toilets and
you know that that's the thing that's
the thing they're doing and so what
percentage of men who convert into women
later on in life it makes you sound like
a religion
You could argue it is a religion
um so uh
what you've just described and how many
of them are suffering from severe gender
dysphoria and they're taking these steps
in order yeah to make themselves feel
better I suppose well those things can
overlap
I mean it's somebody who is doing this
for erotic reasons may also feel great
very grave gender dysphoria
um and I mean and the second part of the
answer is nobody knows because nobody's
doing this research like nobody's asking
genuine questions in comprehensible
language like if you look at any of the
mainstream research on gender issues now
they talk in this distorted ideological
language where they call males females
and females males and they use the wrong
questionnaires for people like you know
if you look at the research on children
for example post-social transition they
will use the questionnaires for the
Target sakes not the real sex so they're
saying things to girls like do you feel
gender dysphoric when you have to stand
up to pee well of course not because she
doesn't stand up to pee
because they're pretending this girl is
now a boy so the research is just
unbelievably crap
I can't you know you actually have to
read the whole thing to find out what
the hell they did the the summary of it
will be rubbish the reporting of it will
be rubbish and then you'll find out that
probably the research itself was rubbish
so I can't answer you any of these sort
of how many numbers but the other thing
I would say is that gender dysphoria is
something that Society creates
so there's not a set amount of gender
dysphoria there's not a set number of
people who are likely to develop gender
dysphoria you know if you live in a
society where gender roles are very
strict and where the only way that you
can do things uh that you really want to
do is by pretending to be the opposite
sex or if we encourage these things by
certain sorts of pornography or someone
you're going to see more gender
dysphoria I mean I would say most of
these men who have an erotic fixation on
becoming a woman are very gender
dysphoric their bodies cause them great
distress
so you know it's not an either or thing
I do think we have to think like how do
you accommodate someone who's that
miserable but ideally like stop them
from getting that miserable in the first
place
but after that yes they do need
accommodation I'm not I'm not trying to
be unsympathetic when I say it's an
erotic fixation
like erotic fixations can be pretty
miserable
I don't think you're being unsympathetic
at all and actually you I love the way
you're very clear about it and it is
funny to me that people would say that
you're hateful or bigoted when you're
just describing these things in a very
neutral way actually I would say
um and it's interesting what you say
because only a few days ago Ollie London
uh the guy who thought he was a Korean
woman was here and we had a very good
conversation actually he's very sound uh
having come through that whole process
and I realized it was it was a mistake
but that was one of the things that
really struck me about what what he said
because he said well Society tells you
you can be anything so why can't I be
Korean
and that to your point about there's not
a set amount of gender dysphoria I mean
that to me is the really scary part of
this which is
someone is looking online they are
feeling as you said that they don't
quite fit in a point that Ollie made
many many times he said well I went to
Korea and suddenly I feel like I fit in
so maybe I'm Korean you know but there
have always been lots of people who
didn't fit in who were bullied at school
or whatever but now just open your phone
and the answers are all there yeah and
and it's funny how some things you're
allowed and some things you aren't it
was very controversial that Ollie London
said that he was Korean but if he had
been an American person who said they
were black yes as we saw with Rachel
dollar like that was just social death
like the woman became a global hate
figure for saying that like white woman
who said that she was black and you know
she she had the sort of the hair and the
skin color that allowed her to do a
fairly decent pretense of that so you
know I ask yourself like why is it okay
for a man to say he's a woman but it's
not okay for a white person to say that
they're blank
and you know in Academia the reason is
that these are only can completely
separate Fields like one of them is in
critical race Theory and one of them is
in queer Theory
and in critical race Theory it's like
whiteness is original sin yeah I mean it
literally is that if you're wise you
must atone for that for the rest of your
life and you will never be finished
atoning and you will never get to the
point that you can say you are not
racist sorry man you have to be
anti-racist all your life you know and
so you could never allow a white person
to identify as a black person then
because they can identify out of their
sin right whereas if you move over to
queer Theory this is this post-modern
field where categories are evil
and we we make we make Utopia by
destroying categories
so you know if you're theorizing male
and female within that it's good to
destroy the categories but I think
that's a contingent explanation like I
don't think it's a chance that those two
Fields grew up the way they did like I
think critical race Theory very much
follows on
from American history of race like from
this you know because it just doesn't
make any sense anywhere else it doesn't
make sense there either but what I mean
is you know you can see where it came
from whereas you look somewhere else and
it's just obviously important whereas
the the queer Theory thing the reason
that that's where sex landed is because
there are men who want to be women and
they want it more than anything else and
those men have the drive to make it
happen because it's their erotic Drive
they have the money because some of them
are rich they have nothing else to be
thinking about so they make it happen
because the way that you can kind of see
this must be the case is if you look at
what trans activism is
it's not what you would do if your
concern was trans people
I mean trans people do have poor health
outcomes poor mental health low income
all of those things so you would have
policies focused on that
but actually the policy is exclusively
focused on gender self-identification
which is legally changing your sex which
means that you can go into spaces for
the opposite sex so the policy is
clearly formed for the benefit of people
whose fixation is to count as the member
of the opposite sex not people who just
want to try and get by while being
highly unusual you know I was watching a
documentary on Rachel dolezel and she
and it was after she was exposed and she
went to do a talk at this University and
the talk was done to black students and
this girl put her hand up afterwards and
went I don't think you can call yourself
black and she was like why not and she
went because you haven't earned the
right to be black and I found that so
interesting I was like no she can't call
herself black because she isn't black
but you haven't earned the right oh it
isn't it very odd like the equivalent
I've seen of that in trans is when
people say that trans women are better
women than what they would call CIS
women and I'd call actual women uh
because they worked for it
because what didn't land on their lap
and you're like I just
I think lands on anybody's lap in the
way of which sex they are like you know
when an egg meets a sperm and they
combine they form a male person or a
female person that's the way it works it
is that simple do you think part of it
as well it's just that you know when I
grew up it was more kind of you know it
was sort of better to be a boy you know
boys were cooler and now you just see
slogans a future is female women are
doing better in the workplace they're
earning more money more of them are
going to University you know it's a
women's it's a woman's world yeah so I
would say that the teenage girls
definitely think that it'd be better to
be a boy like I think it's very easy to
say the grass is greener like you know
you experience you know you think
periods you know getting boobs early
whatever and you think oh and you're
seeing pornography as well by the way
and thinking [ __ ] hell is that what I
meant to do yeah that was disgusting so
so those things would chase a girl away
but then for boys I do I do think
there's something to watch you say
because there's this new category that
we're seeing of teenage boys
transitioning and that was never a group
like it was always the young ones or the
adult ones right so these teenage boys
you look at them and you think
Abby maybe there's something erotic
going on here but it doesn't sound right
and uh I mean these are not people I've
spoken to much because this is a group
that's really just emerging now but
talking to therapists who talk to them
it is partly about this you know being
totally online like they're just
immersed in computer games all the time
but also they've bought into the idea
that of toxic masculinity I mean toxic
masculinity was meant to me there is a
type of masculinity that is toxic which
is true there's also toxic femininity
right
but it's turned into if you're masculine
that's toxic right and so you want to
identify out of that you can't identify
out of being white
you can't identify as some things but
you can always say that you're
non-binary or you can identify as the
opposite sex because that's allowed and
so some of these boys yeah definitely
they they think like that would be nice
girls don't have to try as hard
um you know girls get things bought for
them girls don't have to to take the
initiative which is very scary for a
teenage boy like the idea that you're
going to have to grow into the man who
goes out in business success you know
and you can look at girls and can that's
really that's easy what they're doing is
easy you know put on makeup do your hair
wear short skirts get people to fall
over when they look at you you know
completely unrealistic of course but
that's my point is it's a very
unrealistic idea so yeah I think that
really is happening now for poor boys
hey Francis do you like locals I live in
London Mike so obviously not the only
pleasure I get from the locals is when
we show an intimate moment as we watch a
Japanese tourists get trapped in a tube
door
that is good but I wasn't talking about
their locals I was talking about our
community on locals you mean the one
where you get phenomenal
behind-the-scenes content when you thank
you
when you get lost incredible guests like
Jordan Peterson Brett Weinstein Bill
Burr Sam Harris Adam Carolla Heather
Hein and others your questions not just
that you can get supporter only benefits
like trigonometry mugs monthly calls
with our other top supporters and even a
regular meal with me and Francis you
also get phenomenal behind the scenes
footage of our trip to America where we
met a whole host of incredible guests
and gave ourselves terminal indigestion
we're also starting to do monthly
giveaways for locals only the first one
will be signed copies of Andrew doors
new book plus you get access to an
incredible community of like-minded
people who share memes have fun
conversations and most importantly you
get to make new friends you can support
us with as little as seven dollars or
about five pounds a month or give us
more for the higher tier benefits go to
trigonometry.locals.com go to
trigonometry.locals.com and support the
show
and just touching on the girl issue for
a moment we we've talked about
gay girls girls who have got autism
is there a link as well between
so when I was a teacher in a secondary
school and this was about 10 years ago
now I taught in an all-go school for a
brief period of time there was always a
percentage of the girls who had bulimia
yeah anorexia
body issues for a variety of different
reasons
has that now sort of metamorphosis into
trans or is the bulimia and the anorexia
still there I think part of it's
metamorphized but also their their
comorbidities as the doctors say that
you see them together
so very often you'll see a kid like some
of the kids who are seen at the gender
clinics now will have five or more
conditions wow so you'd be talking about
somebody who is on the autistic spectrum
is trans identified is cutting
themselves has an eating disorder and is
anxious
and unfortunately you walk into a gender
Clinic with that combination of things
and they go oh you're trans
like instead of saying show me your arms
can I see those marks on your arms
please talk to me about that or you know
you're very thin can we talk about that
you know so so you're getting someone
sorry to interrupt Helen but I think
this is important to emphasize you're
getting someone who's clearly
extraordinarily distressed yes and
you're going oh well your explanation
for this is the right one okay let's go
let's let's go along with it so there
was a woman she's quite responsible to
me
that is a very kind way to put it the
day I decided to write my book because
I've been thinking about it for months
and I had been wondering whether I was
the right person because it becomes the
finance editor of The Economist at the
time it's not really very obvious
subject for a book
um for that person uh but also I just
knew that it would mean that I
essentially had to abandon everything
else I was trying to do because you're
not allowed to talk about this and talk
about anything else it just it just
makes you mean by whom it's just if you
try and do something else people will
just not hire you not not get you to
come and talk you know you don't get to
do you don't get to just be a
commentator of any on anything else if
you talk about this because they will
just not use you so you know that it's
just a life-changing decision to write a
book like that I haven't thought of that
but so basically if you start talking
about trans you will not be able to talk
about anything else you will not you
will ruin everything else you will be
dropped by people if you look at the few
Sports people for example who've spoken
on the trans issue in sports they just
don't get to be you know just
commentators they just get dropped for
other things but so the day I decided to
do it was the day that I met my first D
transitioners and as it happens they
were all girls and all lesbian but
that's absolutely not the case generally
that's just what this group was and one
of them was 23 and she had been very
severely bulimic in her teenage years
and have been hospitalized a few times
because she was going to die otherwise
and then when she was 18 she
unfortunately looked up online if it was
possible to get your breasts removed
without having breast cancer like she
wants for reasons to do with weight like
she was trying to get rid of them like
very tiny but she wanted to get rid of
them and she found Top surgery
and a week later she had decided that
she was a trans man and when she went to
a gender Clinic it
the therapist said to her that's why
you're trying to starve yourself because
you're not meant to have curves because
you're really a boy
and so she told her parents and her
parents were delighted because they had
seen their daughter nearly die and they
were like yeah yeah if this is going to
save you you do this
so she got her ovaries removed her
uterus removed she took testosterone she
was getting ready for phalloplasty which
is the most brutal surgery imaginable
where they take off an enormous chunk of
either your leg or your arm and turn it
into a fake dick and you know the it
it's very non-functional and B enormous
numbers of complications
and you know none of it made her any
happier like she was still starving
herself
um so she looked online then um you know
what do I do after a hysterectomy
because she still felt terrible because
they lied to her about how easy all
these operations are hysterectomies are
really tough operations and she was only
21 when she had hers
and she found all these sites of women
who had uterine cancer or you know that
sort of thing and they were very
supportive
as you started talking to them and then
one day the sentence floated into her
mind and it was just how can an
operation that is only done on women
turn me into a man
and it was like the whole thing the
whole past five years just Unwound and
she was back and she was like all of
this was nonsense
and I listened to her tell this story
and I just sat there and I thought oh
[ __ ] hell they are sterilizing gay
kids
and you just think that's a human rights
abuse if I've ever heard of one
do you know that is the most horrible
story that is just awful and the odd
thing to me is that we've somehow ended
up in a position
where not endorsing that and not
supporting that makes you uncaring and
unsympathetic so she was kind of like
Twitter she was kicked off Twitter
because a trans woman said to her how am
I any less of a woman than you you don't
have a uterus either
and she said because you're a man she
lost her Twitter account
a woman who had been through that a
woman who had been subjected to
gross medical negligence
and human rights abuse for just pointing
out that a woman having her uterus
removed is not the same as a man who
wishes to be a woman and it doesn't have
uterus obviously because he's a man you
know when you when you describe it in
that way and you know we've got uh that
we're going to have a couple of people
who are detransitioners coming on the
show uh in 2023
um and I've talked to people like that
and there's all sorts of other things
going on when it's described in this way
I mean I don't think there's anybody in
their right mind who could be on board
with this I I struggled to imagine
however as long as the issues kept
superficial then you're a bigger for not
accepting people the way they are and
whatever and it's sort of easy to to
maintain that way but this is medical
malpractice there's no question about it
that is what it is and it's absolutely
awful and it's brutal however
I heard you talking to our good friend
Winston Marshall
about yet another aspect of this whole
thing that's almost more horrible even
than that which is sex offenders in
prison and and and being conflated with
trans to some extent talk to us about
that
I mean when I started looking into all
of this there were a few things that I
thought like you that as soon as you
said them clearly nobody could disagree
with you
and one of those was that if you allow
anyone to say that they are whichever
sex they choose you will end up moving
rapists into women's jails like that's
just like a theorem you know and it
doesn't even take very many steps and I
thought as soon as I said that to
somebody who said trans women are women
so I said to them yeah but if that's the
case then we will end up putting rapists
in women's jails they would go oh yeah I
didn't think about that
turns out they don't
turns out people don't give a [ __ ]
they don't care about prisoners I think
I don't think it's They Don't Care About
Women particularly prisoners so it's a
black box prisons are black boxers you
don't see what goes on inside them but
you're pretty sure pretty terrible
things go on inside them
and there's an undertone of what those
people deserve it and not always just an
undertone
I mean even people who think of
themselves as good liberal people who
believe in the rule of law and so on
will say that you know a pedophile
deserves what he gets in prison
that surprised me because I don't think
that like I believe in the rule of law I
think you know we have a justice system
because we don't want that sort of
extrajudicial way of thinking about
things I'm sorry I just don't think it's
right
and then when you think about women in
prison you don't even need to be
thinking about the arguments about
whether pedophiles deserve what they get
in prison because women in prison is so
unlike men in prison
like one day I looked at the statistics
and I thought you know there is nowhere
you will see the difference between men
and women more
except on the maternity ward
so if you look at prisons right nearly
all prisoners are men like 96 or
something like that
and of those about a fifth of sex
offenders so you've got tens of
thousands of violent prisoners Who
Remain and maybe 20 000 ish or 15 000
ish who are in for a sex offense now we
know that most rapes don't get reported
we know that even the ones that get
reported don't lead to convictions so
loads of the other prisoners are going
to be rapists too they just weren't ever
caught because these are violent men who
are willing to break the law right some
of them will be rapists
tens of thousands of rapists right
you've got four thousand women roughly
three and a half thousand four thousand
women mostly in there for non-payment of
fines often TV license soliciting drug
offenses theft that sort of thing most
of them have experienced domestic
violence
you know most of them have been have
suffered very much at the hands of men
you know specifically
uh very few violent offenses and really
almost no sexual offenses and the sexual
offenses are often um in in partnership
with somebody else women who go to jail
for sex offenses it's often that they
worked with a man to create child
pornography
or you know they were soliciting they
were part of a brothel type situation
it's not because they forced themselves
on people it's hard for women to force
themselves on people
anyway so that's so you just
unbelievably different populations and
add to that the fact that men are much
much stronger than women
now you've got some men that you can say
would you like would you like to say
that you're a woman and move over there
like men male prisoners are not male
prisons are not very nice like I don't
know how naive you have to be to not
think that this is going to lead to some
strategic decisions to transition
is it do you think they're not naive or
they just I interpret it as they don't
want to think like that so for instance
it's it's like you know the migrant
crisis where you hear somebody on on the
left go I think they should just all be
allowed to come here and you go well
you're not really thinking about the
long-term implications you're not
thinking about the impact that's going
to have on people you're not thinking
about the impact that's going to have on
what's going to happen further down the
line You're just showing your care for
people who are struggling I think that's
not a good analogy because you know
solving the migrant crisis would
actually take Serious efforts like you'd
actually have to do something and you'd
have to spend money and you'd have to
think about policies and you'd have to
accept you know maybe more or if you
were drownings but some drownings
whatever like it's tough tough choices
have to be made there's no tough choices
here we've got male prisons and female
prisons there's literally no problem we
were doing it the right way before I
think it's you know this word privilege
is is overused but it's mostly just
badly used it's privilege it's the fact
that the people who are talking about
this are never going to be there
themselves you are looking at the people
who are in the hardest situation in the
world when you're looking at some of the
prisoners especially these women in
prison you know these are women who are
away from their Partners their way their
children their Partners have left them
you know it's just people that you know
like I'm literally I'm never going to be
there
and so if you are attached to this
ideology for reasons to do entirely with
battery signaling in my opinion uh this
is a very inconvenient thought the
thought that prisons are a place that
show that this was a bad thing to do and
the thing about prisoners is you can
lock them off they're black boxers you
can just not pay attention to what's
inside them so they do you know it's
it's a price that you're willing for
someone else to pay well exactly right
and I suppose this is where the
conversation about erotic uh
the erotic side of it comes in because
are you arguing that there are no people
who who might be claiming to be a trans
woman who are also not a threat no we're
not claiming that at all no no I don't I
didn't think you were but I just wanted
to check yeah so I don't think that
trans women who are men are any more or
any less likely in general to be threats
than men okay right but then because
they are men exactly men are men commit
nearly all the violent crime men commit
nearly all the sexual offenses men are
much stronger than women but also it's
not just about threat like I think
whenever I talk about prisons to policy
makers somebody will say but how many
rapes are there or you talk about
changing rooms they'll say how many
rapes are there I mean we have changing
rooms and separate prisons partly to
stop rapes but also just because it's
kind of embarrassing undressing in front
of people of the opposite sex like
you know modesty is a thing and most
people feel more comfortable in Intimate
situations with people of the same sex
uh you know it's not that you'd Nest I
mean like if
in my workplace
if we were to switch to go gender
neutral toilets I actually don't think
I'll work with anybody at The Economist
who would have caused me problems I
still don't want them in the bloody
changing rooms with me if they're men
it's that simple so yeah I mean
the reason I raise that point is I
suppose my uh concern there would be
that the a trans woman who is just a
trans woman yeah right being forced to
be in a male prison yes makes her very
violent yeah you you make a very very
good point them or her whatever you say
whatever pronoun you want that person is
going to be much more vulnerable as a
result simply of the fact that they
identify as trans well probably probably
as a result of the fact that they appear
feminine or female to whatever extent
they do yeah so that's that's an
excellent point and that points the way
that we should think about these
problems
so you know if trans women are women
then trans women belong in women's
prisons whereas if we accept that trans
women are an unusually vulnerable group
of men well then we think how do we deal
with this unusual capable group of men
and actually prisons have a lot of
groups of vulnerable men young men are
very vulnerable in prison gay men are
very vulnerable in prison police
officers are very vulnerable so by the
way are pedophiles and other sex
offenders and this is not me saying that
trans women are sex offenders I just
mean that prisons manage very vulnerable
groups they may have to manage gangs
they try and keep drugs out you know
this is just another vulnerable group of
men and should be thought of that way
uh so for example perhaps to a separate
wing will be a good would be a good
answer you know and if if you if you
think although I don't anymore but if
you think that allowing
people to present as members of the
opposite sex is a good treatment for
this feeling of gender dysphoria then
you may need to have a separate
accommodation for them in order to
accommodate that because that's not
something you normally accommodate in
men's prisons but you don't think
transitioning of any kind is is good I
don't have any evidence that it is I
mean maybe it is for some but I just
don't think that research is being done
there are people who will tell you that
they're much happier and I can't tell
them that they're not
but I mean I also know that you know the
only decent long-term results of uh
following following on people who have
gone through the full transition surgery
and so on uh it doesn't show that these
are people who have normal levels of
mental health but they're 20 times more
suicidal for example
as in likely to complete a suicide uh
now they might have been worse if they
hadn't transitioned of course but I'm
saying it's not like it turns somebody
into someone who has no problems anymore
no well I mean we have had people on the
show uh uh Buck Angel Rose of dawn uh uh
Debbie Hayden for example yeah who would
all say that transitioning was the right
decision for them and it really helped
them and they they're living a a the
life that they they want to be living no
but just think though if you had gone
through that amount of surgery and so on
are you are you somebody who can
seriously say you know what this is a
bit of a waste of time well clearly a
lot of people are saying that now D
transition I think that's because
they're actually in they're distraught
like we the only way that you can know
whether a medical treatment is better
than doing nothing is by doing what are
called prospective studies you start
from before the treatment and you offer
different treatments and you follow up
so it could be that you've got people
who say you know this was great I do
feel better they're going to feel better
without doing it
like you just don't know this and far be
it from me to say that these people
would have been happier if they hadn't
transitioned I can't say that yeah my
sense of I mean Buck Angel we did
remotely but Debbie and Rose of Dawn
when we had her in particular uh my
sense and look what does my sense matter
but it was these are people pretty
comfortable with who they are yeah yeah
but I just don't work for them yeah it
works for them
um and that's fine I don't know Rose
although I follow her on Twitter and I
do know Debbie uh
but if you think like what does living
as a member of the opposite sex mean
I come back to this thing of it means
using spaces that aren't intended for
you
so accommodating transition is something
that Society has to do when nobody asks
the rest of us and in particular nobody
asks women
so if you can transition and that's what
will make you happier but that means
that you're going to be going into
spaces where frankly you're just not
welcome
you're in a very difficult position like
you're going to transition and not use
those spaces
if would you have transitioned if you'd
known you weren't going to use those
spaces because the doctors haven't been
asking the doctors never asked they just
said to these blokes like usually they
would have a real life test first a year
or two before surgery and we should say
really so that anyone listening to this
hardly anyone has surgery literally
nearly hearty anyone who calls
themselves trances at any sort of
surgery so we are talking about
physiologically normal people for their
own sex usually
but if you want to go through that
surgery they will say to you live as a
member of the opposite sex for a year or
two what they mean is dress makeup
whatever
and go into the women's toilets go into
the women's changing rooms see everyone
shout at you and shove you out
uh of course they're not going to
shuffle you out they're terrified of you
you're a bloke who's willing to overstep
woman's boundaries to the extent that
you've come into the women's changing
rooms that's a very scary man
so what happens is the women leave as
fast as they can
and then at the end of that year or two
years you go back to your doctor and you
say gosh that was a huge success lovely
beautifully integrated into the changing
rooms they do the surgery and now you
keep using the changing rooms but you
know
I'm sorry this is not okay none of this
is okay so if saying some people will be
happier if they transition means that
those people get to use faces they're
not entitled to I'm not okay with it
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website because if you do then
easy DNS is a company for you easy DNS
is the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be canceled culture D
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows about that
so will you in a second easy DNS have
Rock Solid Network infrastructure and
fantastic customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you know about that move your
domains and websites over to easy DNS
right now all you've got to do is go to
easydns.com forward slash triggered
that's easydns.com forward slash
triggered use our promo code which is
also triggered and get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy which tells
you everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
let's talk a little bit about the
ideology because
I mean
weird
isn't it just I wish I could be more
articulate and erudite it's just weird
but it is
weird you're just going I don't
understand this the leaps of logic the
the and you you try and read this kind
of because I've tried I've sat down and
I've read this stuff and I'm but I can't
get my head around it what's going on
I mean partly I think it's because it's
basically a new religion and you're not
meant to get your head around religions
specifically you're not meant to any
attempt to get around it is showing that
you don't have faith
so to me it's very like I was brought up
Catholic although I no longer really
believe and I feel your pain yeah okay
so but you know three gods in one I
remember the mystery of the Trinity yes
of course right it's not meant to try to
understand that and you're certainly not
meant to say okay three Gods equals one
therefore in any equation in order
mathematics three equals one yeah you
know it's it's ineffable it's a mystery
and so there's an aspect of that about
us that you're not meant to try to
explain it you're just meant to to
recite the Creed and the Creed you know
trans women or women have you ever seen
any of these things where they have
protests and there'll be a call and
answer very like a religious call an
answer so somebody who has the mic
called Bello trans women are women and
then everyone goes trans women are women
and it just reminds me of Lord hear us
Lord graciously hear us
so yeah I don't think you're meant to
understand it you're just meant to
accept it because and then there's
another and I'm loath to talk about this
because but I feel we have to talk about
it because it's it's what's going on now
and then the kind of
the fact that a lot of these people who
created some of these ideologies had to
pedophilic pass yeah and
again I feel uncomfortable talking about
it but you're meant to feel comfortable
talking about it that's that's the point
you're meant to feel uncomfortable so
you don't talk about it so we don't do
our child safeguarding that's the way it
works but so so let's have the
conversation so what's going on with
that
I mean I don't think that pedophilia is
a big part of any sort of motivation on
Trends specifically
the fact is that
um queer Theory this idea that
boundaries are bad you know innately
suspicious things and that we can
redefine everything and you know we can
turn the world upside down that's very
useful for pedophiles
so I think it's almost the other way
around so this is an ideology that is
useful for pedophiles so it will attract
them so if you ever talk to a child
safeguarding expert they'll say to you
that if you work with vulnerable people
and specifically vulnerable children
you have to be super suspicious-minded
and you have to make that really clear
to everyone because if you don't you
become a beacon
which attracts the wrong people because
other people are being careful and
you're not
so queer theories like that it attracts
the wrong sort of people because in
other places there are people going hmm
why does that bloke want to call himself
a woman and get into the women's prison
you know why does that man have this
weird obsession with the fact the
childhood is a you know post-industrial
Western concept
but in queer Theory they're like oh
that's interesting you're querying
childhood
so of course encounter bloody pedophiles
into that field that's the way it works
again
by no means everybody in queer theory is
a peat of oil it's the other way around
the opposite Point you're making the
point is the the queer Theory attracts
attracts them yeah so where are we
getting these do you remember last I
think I can't remember it was uh I think
it was in the course of the last year we
had this uh what was it called the show
in Bristol oh yeah
yeah I have a p the lyrics I still
remember I wish I didn't I have a penis
in my pants touch it touch it touch it
and all this kind of stuff I I can't
open Twitter without some [ __ ] drag
queen twerking harassing a
three-year-old's face yeah like where is
all this coming from I mean I don't
think that most of the people involved
in drag queen Story Hour are pedophiles
I think that they're very careless and
so there will be pedophiles coming in
but so why are they so interested in
dealing in getting in in front of
children and why are the parents there
just clapping this along so they're
getting interested in being in front of
children is because of the Jesuit thing
give me the child until E7 and I'll show
you the man right right so if you want
to teach children if you want to teach
people if you want the world to think
that male and female are arbitrary
categories start with kids and
specifically little kids are good for
this because little kids do think that
what makes you a man or a woman is your
clothes yeah like a three-year-old does
think that they think that if you take a
boy doll and you dress it to be a girl
it becomes a Girl doll now actually
that's true for dolls because dolls
don't have Sexes but you know what I
mean they think about people too but by
the time they're six or seven they've
worked out that it's the body so
interrupt that process and you've got
people who will really think the trans
women are women forevermore
and then just in a very pragmatic level
drag queen Story Hour means getting
blokes dolled up to look like really
really hypersexualized parodies of women
to come into schools and be called she
in front of kids like there's nothing
better for preparing them for thinking
that trans women are women
and then if you look at what they read
as well they read gender identity
[ __ ] they read all these stories
about you know non-binary teddy bears
and a dolphin who thought he was a boy
but he's really a girl stuff you know so
it's actually indoctrination that's why
they're doing it it's indoctrination I
don't think it's for pedophilic purposes
although I think it's an easy Avenue for
it it's it's because it's indoctrination
why do the parents do it we're back to
the [ __ ] virtue signaling aren't we
Source it was very boring I mean you
have a small baby but it's very boring
being at home as a mother with a toddler
somebody wants to put on maybe you liked
it
right
drag queen Story Hour or maybe you like
to drag yourself when you're in your
teens or 20s or even maybe your 30s I
hate the bloody thing myself it's just
so boring like it manages to be both
boring and quite kind of terrifying at
the same time which is a an amazing feat
the drug is a legitimate part of the the
creative arts and always has been and
you know but suppose you were like in
your 20s or 30s like you had nice you
know girls nights out and you went to a
drag bar and so on it's kind of um it's
kind of you're cool again aren't you and
you're a cool mom you're not like boring
mom
I suppose another way of looking at it
is you know well we go to the pantomime
bloke dresses up as you know as a
pantomime I've seen that much twerking
have you heard of this it's sometimes
called the fallacy of the beard
so it's meant to be about where there
are things that really are different
things but the boundary between them is
fuzzy so you've got somebody who's
clean-shaven and then you give them like
one hair have they got a beard no two
hairs have they got a beard no what are
you talking about me
I don't know I don't actually know how
many hairs there are in a beard but
let's say it's ten thousands this person
has a beard yeah but there was no point
in between what you you know was
clear-cut whether it was beard or no
beard so then somebody says well nobody
has beards or everybody has beards like
another example would be to say you know
dusk what's dusk is that day timer is
that nighttime oh there's no day or
night
and so this is a bit of a long preamble
to saying yes there's a bit of drag in
pantos yes there can be smutty innuendo
they're tertiary characters it's a
little bit of it it's usually older men
it's very far away they're not reading
you [ __ ] about you know non-binary
Penguins or whatever the hell it is in
school it's all of those things it's
right up close it's only that it's
hypersexualized there's no other
storyline it's not aiming over the heads
of the kids at the grown-ups who just
want to laugh at some dirty joke so you
know these are different things even
though it'd be hard to say where the
boundary exactly lay between panto and
drag queen but they're just obviously
different right hello we're coming
towards the end and there's a couple of
very important questions
um that I want to cover before before we
we wrap up and number one in my mind is
I've sort of gone through this year 2022
so this may go out next year may go out
this year thinking well look we're
making progress in the UK right you know
the Tavistock mermaids you know the gra
all of this stuff are we making in
progress are we doing well on this issue
in this country yes we are making
progress and we're making more progress
than anywhere else as well uh it's going
to get worse before it gets better
because uh they all had they had it
their own way for a long time there was
institutional capture there was nobody
calling anything out there were just a
lot of things changing behind the scenes
now it's all in public and they're angry
and the specific people who are going to
be most angry are those who have made
irrevocable choices on the basis that
the rest of us would go along with those
choices
most of all the parents who transition
to their own children because if you
transition your own child you're in
effect making a promise to that child
that the whole world is going to step in
line for the entire rest of that child's
life
and now there's people like me saying
actually that's not going to happen you
can tell your boy that he's your
daughter if you like but he's not going
to be able to play in women's sports and
I'm going to fight tooth and nail to get
him out of women's changing rooms as
well
those people are all in you know they've
bet the house they bet their lives on an
ideology that we're now fighting back
against they're going to fight to the
death on this
so it's going to be it's going to keep
going
and the other thing is this isn't a
Tipping Point kind of situation like
people often say if we reach the Tipping
Point it's the wrong analogy we've seen
very serious institutional capture we've
watched it turned out our institutions
were rotten
like any institution that you could go
to and say is it all right if the men
can count as women here and they didn't
say you're having a laugh [ __ ] off is a
rotten institution it turned out they
were all rotten
this has made them more rotten and now
we have to try and win them back it's
going to be really hard like how do you
get back Stonewall you can't it's dead
we've got to get rid of it and replace
it you know what do you do with the ioc
you know the international Olympic
Committee that has allowed men to
compete as women I mean we don't have
control over it but it's rotten you know
so I think it's just going to be
absolute hard graft for years and years
to try to get back to just where we were
and it's not like you know the world was
a perfect place before that you know
there was still homophobia there was
still sexism etc etc there were still
bad things happening domestic violence
rape whatever and all of those things on
hold just because we've got to try and
fix this idiotic problem well this is
the second question I think this is the
most important one because I I agree
with you and with myself that we're
making progress yes I agree with me as I
should but
we talked about where this has come from
right and part of that is technology
part of that is all the other stuff that
we've discussed today
and those are quite fundamental things
that have changed and we I think it's
fair to say technology is going to keep
advancing it's going to get easier to
transition it's going to get I mean
Ollie London who sat in that chair four
days ago whenever it was spanked a
quarter of a million dollars uh to be
Korean yeah I think it's 70 or 80
surgeries he said I've met him briefly
once he's had a lot of surgery and yeah
look and if if uh if a
20-something-year-old guy who's on on
Instagram and Tick Tock and whatever can
just go and do that
it's going to get more accessible it's
going to get easier uh the the Social
Media stuff isn't going away I don't
think I mean we could maybe talk about
what they could be doing but how how do
we how how do we ensure that in this
technologically advancing Society more
of this stuff doesn't happen
I mean free speech is the fundamental
issue for me because I don't think so
much of this would have happened if
we've been able to talk more freely now
a lot of the non-talking has been
because people haven't been brave enough
and and often for very good reason
they're afraid of losing their jobs and
you know if you're afraid of losing your
job I
I can't blame you for staying quiet
people have to put bread on the table so
it's also been censorship on social
media
um you know via law
uh and just just via um employers being
kind of being captured
so I would say first Free Speech because
then we can talk about it clearly and
like you said earlier that people
wouldn't go with this if they understood
what was being said well I mean the
reason they don't understand it is
because we're forced to use this idiotic
Language by calling men women or calling
men she because that's what they think
of themselves as I I may I quibble with
that somewhere Helen just because I
think there's another piece to this
which is most people have busy lives
yeah they've got families they've got
jobs they've got bills to pay they've
got all sorts of other [ __ ] going on and
here comes along this perfectly rational
very nice woman called Helen Joyce and
wants them to think about people
chopping their dicks off and you know
all this shopping or not chopping their
dicks off or you know some man who yeah
they've they've never met a trans person
now I have to think about this no just
go away Helen I don't want to think
about it completely just want to get on
with my life and I think that that is
actually a big part of it too oh
completely very understandable yeah and
very understandable but that's true of
all policies yeah so you know people
don't want to think about brexit they
don't want to think about interest rates
migrants whatever they just want they
pay the government to sort that stuff
out yeah but the people who are being
paid to sort us out
their cowards but also they can't think
through the issues if you can't write
them down or say them logically you have
to be able to keep saying men who think
they're women
you know men who think they're women
should be allowed into women's sports is
nothing like as convincing as trans
women should belong in women's sports so
we need to get the language back I think
that's non-negotiable without that we
can't do anything
um and then I would say yes technology
but more than technology markets like
it's not just that that surgery was
available or all those surgeries were
available for Ollie London it said there
were people willing to provide them
and so in America you know we're not in
this country this is the problem is he
tried to get all this crazy surgery in
this country and he couldn't so he went
to Brazil well to Armenia I think
Thailand somewhere like all over the
place yeah and he could and so we can't
stop that actually and within America
the way it is there is going to be
marketized Health Care like it's the
world's biggest marketized Healthcare
System
but what what's the point in doing it
like I actually think that I don't know
if this is right but I think Ollie
London probably has body dysmorphia yeah
I think it's going to move to something
else I'm afraid
that I hope that he I hope that he can
find stability but someone like that
tends to just keep going they find a new
thing today what's interesting is we
employ someone who has gender dysphoria
and
um religion has actually been a really
helpful thing because it's a new Folly
and to them yes to deal I can imagine
that and I say that as a non-religious
person it's another way to look at the
world and it's a very supportive way to
look at the world so hopefully his newly
found Christianity or refound
Christianity I hope so I really hope so
but you know and so then to move away
from the individual who I don't know and
I'm not as Healthcare professional you
know people who do these like Michael
Jackson style levels of interventions
don't tend to stop it's not like you cut
a bit off your nose and think now my
nose is perfect you just keep cutting
bits off your nose you know so I don't
know that we can stop that but if you if
you if you bring it back to gender if
you can't use spaces for the opposite
sex why would you do it
I I think that by changing the world in
such a way that we have gender self-id
in Single Sex spaces
we are encouraging people to transition
and if we stopped doing that we would
discourage transition
so I do think there's a policy tool
available to us which is to return and
this is why I work for sex matters to
return to the importance of sex-based
Rights in law and everyday life and I
mean the the most important thing that
we can do on this in this country in the
law you probably have heard of the
equality act it's the overarching thing
nine protected characteristics it's a
thing that stops discrimination in
employment and and provision of services
on the basis of sex religion race etc
etc in that it's not clear whether sex
really means sex or whether it means sex
as Modified by a gender recognition
certificate the single most important
thing that we could do in the coming
year in this country is get a small
Amendment and there's a procedure for
doing this this all sounds very techy
and very nerdy but these are my favorite
things when there's like a two-line
thing you could do in a law to say to
say in the equality acts sex actually
means sex the thing that was on your
birthday when you were born
if we did that then we could start
having the cascading work in the other
direction
back into sex meaning sex in Single Sex
spaces Sports etc etc there is a
petition to ask the government to do
this
that sex matter is set up that's the
most important thing that people could
do is sign that petition get a
Westminster Hall debate encourage the
government to do it before Labor come in
and you know and then we could start
moving back reclaim Single Sex spaces
stop encouraging people with this draw
telling them that if they self ID they
can use the opposite sex spaces and then
they won't feel as gendered dysphoric
because this is the thing that annoys me
is that the thought that you could do it
encourages the gender dysphoria
do you think things are going to get
better if we get a labor government
no
I mean in some other ways maybe yes
because we're very much at the tail end
of a long worn out
12-year Administration series you know
so I mean it's not like I'm massively
invested in this government no no I
don't think anyone yeah on this on this
issue I mean of course all the bad
things of the last 12 years have
happened under under the Tories so
they're hardly they hardly have clean
hands but there are more people I'm in
the Tory party who understand that this
is a serious issue than in labor
it's been an absolute pleasure Helen
speaking with you we our last question
is always the same it is what's the one
thing we're not talking about as a
society that we really should be
it's something that we are talking about
but we're talking about it completely
the wrong way and that's kids Mental
Health
so there's a lot of talk about mental
health and if you're if you have a child
in school you'll know that they're um
like literally doing about the worst
things they could possibly be doing for
children's mental health which is
encouraging rumination telling children
to think about you know how do you feel
how do you feel today let's talk about
it learn the words about your feelings
incredibly bad idea all of that unless
you're with a professional
just encouraging people to think and
feel bad
we are creating a mental health crisis
among children it's already really
raging it's going to get worse because
we're doing all the wrong things with
our children they're not getting out and
out enough they're not getting enough
exercise they're spending too much time
on screens
you know friendship groups are becoming
more atomized and less close and then
we're teaching them nonsense in schools
we're teaching them nonsense about their
bodies their identities we're
encouraging them to be fragile uh you
know the sort of the anti-bullying
efforts are just all the wrong ones you
know we're not actually making people
more kind and generous and supportive
we're making them more ready to complain
and expect the grown-ups will step in
and sort it out for them we are creating
a mental health crisis in our kids and I
think it's the most serious thing that
we should be all talking about and doing
something about
Helen Joyce absolutely a brilliant
interview fantastic book trans and we're
going to ask you a couple of questions
that our supporters have submitted that
only they will get to see uh on local so
uh thank you very much and thank you
guys for watching and listening we will
see you very soon with another brilliant
episode like this one or raw show all of
them go out at 7pm UK time and for those
of you who like your trigonometry on the
go it's also available as a podcast take
care and see you soon guys
the gender identity ideology Beast is
like the many headed Hydra for which is
the head that was chopped off will be
the Fatal blow to this Dreadful damaging
creature
foreign
[Music]